so joining us now republican tennessee
senator and member of the senate
judiciary and armed services committee
marcia blackburn she's also going to be
visiting the southern border tomorrow to
get a first hand look
at the situation there senator thank you
so much for joining the show and i'd
like to start
by getting your response to what house
speaker nancy pelosi
said yesterday saying that she believes
the biden administration
has this under control kristen this
is eerily familiar words from nancy
pelosi because in 2015
when the border started getting out of
control after
president obama's daca order which by
the way that's not the law
it was an executive order and she would
say oh it's all under control that's the
first
year that i visited one of these
facilities
came back this is out of control we need
to do something
oh you know you're just saying that
because it's uh
you disagree with the administration but
here is the thing we have a humanitarian
crisis on our border
there are the cartels who have been so
emboldened going through central america
and mexico
and around the globe you have
international
drug cartels human trafficking sex
trafficking cartels and where are they
all coming to work the northern part of
mexico
just south of the u.s border
and for the drug and human and sex
trafficking this is out of control
so no they do not have this border
under control and there are steps they
need to take immediately to get it back
under control so senator you bring up
these uh
humanitarian humanitarian crisis down at
the border and you know it's been tough
for journalists to really get a
first-hand look about what's happening
there
especially in these facilities where the
unaccompanied minors are being housed
because
the body administration really is not
allowing the press in
they say they're working on it but they
haven't yet and so we're having to rely
on the white house and on some of the
local leaders down there to find out
what the conditions are like and listen
to what
texas governor greg abbott said
yesterday
what we learned in midland just in the
past hour
is two things one is they have
no proven clean running water at the
location
they were using well water that the
texas commission on environmental
equality has informed the federal
government
has not been proven to be safe more than
10 percent
of the migrants at the midland location
have now
tested positive for cova 19. so in
midland midland
no clean water for migrants 10 percent
according to the governor testing
positive for kovid
are these the types of issues and
concerns that you're hoping to look into
when you visit the border tomorrow
certainly we want to look into this it
is a concern that you have individuals
with covet
and that are coming in and then also you
do not know
what is coming in via the cartels with
biologics
with weapons and when you have
this kind of policy which obviously this
is the biden administration immigration
policy
is open the border he said he expected
about two million
people to come but to not
make the preparation to not give the
tools
so that the border can be protected
and american citizens can be protected
this is outrageous
they make every town a border town in
every state a border state
because there is no control there is
no uh testing for
covet uh the treatment of these young
girls and women
kristin not knowing what they're walking
into
this is absolutely outrageous
so the flip side of course you have the
binding administration saying
and blaming a lot of this on the trump
administration's policies saying they
dismantled a lot of these
uh intake facilities how do you respond
to that
well that is just not true and
people know that that is not true the
trump administration did build some new
facilities those facilities are now
overrun
uh there were places programs that had
been put in place going back
to george bush's administration
that had been there uh
systems that were in place what did the
biden administration do
they chose to dismantle that they
dismantled
remain in mexico they reinstituted catch
and release
they got rid of the migrant protection
protocols
and why did they do this because they
wanted to throw out the welcome mat
and say y'all come well senator i got to
leave it there i know president biden's
going to be pressed on this on thursday
and please let us know what you find
after you visit the border tomorrow
thank you thank you